Bonjour à tous, aujourd’hui on va parler
d’un sujet extrêmement familier et pourtant
encore méconnu : le verre.
Le verre c’est un matériau étonnant qu’on
retrouve tout autour de nous dans notre quotidien.
Mais qui est utilisé aussi bien pour faire
de l’art que des produits de haute technologie.
Et dans cette vidéo, on va se demander notamment
: qu’est-ce que c’est vraiment le verre
?
[jingle]
Pour comprendre ce qu’est le verre, on va
commencer par regarder à quoi il ressemble
au niveau microscopique.
Vous savez qu’on distingue classiquement
3 principaux états de la matière : les solides,
les liquides et les gaz.
[ETATS Les solides ont une disposition périodique
et régulière de leurs atomes, on parle de
structure cristalline, et cela leur donne
notamment leur rigidité.
De leur côté les liquides ont un arrangement
complètement désordonné de leurs molécules.
Celles-ci sont proches les unes des autres,
comme dans un solide, mais sans organisation
cristalline.
Et c’est ce qui fait qu’un liquide coule.
Il n’est pas rigide, et il va donc prendre
la forme de son contenant.
Et enfin pour les gaz, les atomes ou molécules
sont également distribués de façon désordonnée,
mais en étant plus éloignées les uns des
autres, avec beaucoup moins d’interactions
entre eux.]
A vue de nez, le verre a plutôt l’air d’un
solide : il est dur, il est rigide.
Et pourtant quand on étudie sa structure
microscopique, on peut se rendre compte qu’il
est en fait organisé comme un liquide.
Il n’a pas de structure cristalline, et
l’arrangement de ses constituants est totalement
désordonné.
[STRUCTURE Les différents atomes sont assez
liés entre eux, comme dans un solide, mais
d’une façon qui ne présente aucune régularité.
On dit parfois que le verre est un solide
amorphe.]
C’est-à-dire qu’au niveau macroscopique,
il a tout l’air d’un solide, et se comporte
comme tel.
Mais au niveau microscopique, il a une structure
de liquide.
Une autre façon de le penser, c’est de
dire que le verre est comme un liquide qui
serait hyper hyper visqueux.
Tellement visqueux qu’il serait dur, rigide,
et ne coulerait pas, ou pas de façon visible.
Alors pourquoi pas, le verre serait donc une
sorte d’état intermédiaire de la matière,
à la fois un peu solide, à la fois un peu
liquide…sauf qu’il y a un truc qui cloche
avec ce que je raconte.
Vous savez que pour faire du verre, on fait
essentiellement fondre du sable.
Alors en général, pas que du sable mais
on y reviendra.
Le sable, c’est principalement des grains
de quartz, dont la formule est SiO2, c’est
du dioxyde de silicium aussi appelé silice.
[QUARTZ Or le quartz a une structure cristalline
qui est bien connue, vous la voyez ici.
On a les atomes de silicium et les atomes
d’oxygène.
Il y a deux fois plus d’oxygène que de
silicium, donc c’est bien SiO2 en moyenne.
Et le quartz est par conséquent un solide
cristallin bien comme il faut, il rentre parfaitement
dans la définition d’un solide.]
La température de fusion du quartz, donc
du sable, c’est environ 1700°C.
Mais c’est bizarre : si le verre c’est
fait à partir du sable fondu, pourquoi à
température ambiante le verre serait un liquide,
même très visqueux.
Il ne devrait pas !
A température ambiante, on est très largement
en dessous de la température de fusion du
quartz, donc le verre ça ne devrait pas avoir
une structure amorphe.
Ca devrait juste à nouveau du quartz, avec
sa structure cristalline.
Qu’est-ce qu’il s’est passé ? Eh bien
pour le comprendre, il faut s’intéresser
à comment on fait du verre, quel est son
procédé de fabrication.
Pour étudier ça, on va rester pour commencer
sur le cas du sable pur, donc du quartz SiO2.
Imaginons qu’on le chauffe assez, bien au-delà
de sa température de fusion, disons allez
à 2500°C.
A cette température, on a aura un vrai liquide,
et sa viscosité sera à peu près celle d’un
miel bien épais.
On l’a dit, en théorie, quand va refroidir
ce liquide en dessous de sa température de
fusion de 1700°C, il devrait cristalliser,
redevenir du quartz.
Mais en pratique, ce phénomène de cristallisation,
il n’est pas immédiat.
Et plus le liquide est visqueux, plus la cristallisation
va être difficile, et lente à s’effectuer.
Si on fait redescendre suffisamment vite la
température de notre quartz fondu, il va
devenir de plus en plus visqueux sans avoir
le temps de commencer à cristalliser.
Et il faut voir que la viscosité d’un liquide
de ce genre varie énormément quand on baisse
la température.
[VISCOSITE Le graphique que je vous mets ici
représente une variation typique de viscosité
qu’on obtiendrait en fonction de la température.
Sur l’axe horizontal, on a donc la température,
en degré Celsius.
Sur l’axe vertical, la viscosité.
L’unité de viscosité c’est le Pascal.seconde.
Mais notez bien que cet axe est en échelle
logarithmique.
Il se passe donc la chose suivante : quand
baisse en température, la viscosité augmente
énormément.
Quand on passe sous la température de fusion,
en théorie la cristallisation devrait commencer,
mais en pratique le liquide est déjà tellement
visqueux que cela étouffe en quelque sorte
le phénomène de cristallisation.]
En le refroidissant, on a piégé notre matériau
dans un état liquide très visqueux, un état
de solide amorphe, et sa vitesse de cristallisation
maintenant est quasi nulle.
Il ne peut plus cristalliser, bien qu’il
soit en-dessous de sa température de fusion.
Et c’est ça qui explique que quand on fait
fondre du sable, du quartz et qu’on le refroidit
assez vite, on ne retrouve pas du quartz,
mais du verre.
Vous connaissez peut-être une autre situation
où on peut avoir un liquide qui ne devrait
normalement pas en être un : ce qu’on appelle
la surfusion de l’eau.
L’idée est la suivante.
Si on refroidit de l’eau à une température
inférieure à 0°C, vous le savez, ça devient
de la glace.
C’est un phénomène de cristallisation,
et pour l’eau, il n’y a pas de problème
de viscosité qui l’empêcherait ou la ralentirait.
Mais pour cette cristallisation puisse démarrer,
il lui faut tout de même un phénomène déclencheur.
Généralement une toute petite vibration
ou la simple présence d’une petite impureté
ou de sels minéraux suffit.
Et en pratique, quand on met de l’eau au
congélateur, elle cristallise toujours pour
faire de la glace.
[SURFUSION Mais si on s’y prend avec délicatesse
et de l’eau assez pure, il est techniquement
possible de refroidir de l’eau liquide en-dessous
de 0°C, sans qu’elle ne gèle tout de suite.
Cette eau, on dit alors qu’elle est en surfusion.
Il est possible de manipuler cette eau surfusion,
qui peut conserver cet état liquide temporaire,
mais il faut savoir qu’un simple choc ou
la présence d’une impureté va très vite
déclencher sa cristallisation.]
Mais tant que cela ne se produit pas, l’eau
en surfusion reste donc dans un état liquide,
qu’en principe elle ne devait pas avoir.
Et donc c’est comme avec le verre : dans
les deux cas, on arrive à préserver un état
amorphe, liquide, même si on se trouve en
dessous de la température de fusion.
Et donc on dit parfois aussi que le verre
est un liquide en surfusion.
Evidemment le mécanisme qui explique cette
surfusion est différent dans les deux matériaux
: pour l’eau en surfusion, c’est l’absence
d’impuretés qui empêche la cristallisation,
et pour le verre c’est la viscosité.
Ce qui est pratique avec le verre, c’est
que puisque la viscosité ralentit ainsi la
cristallisation, on a la possibilité de le
travailler, de lui donner la forme qu’on
veut, avant de le ramener à température
ambiante.
Et même sans prendre trop de précautions,
la cristallisation est tellement lente qu’en
pratique on est quasi-certains de rester dans
l’état amorphe.
Mais alors si c’est tellement facile et
naturel de rester dans cet état amorphe,
et si c’est tellement difficile de cristalliser,
comment on peut expliquer que les cristaux
de quartz qui constituent le sable puissent
exister ?
Eh bien il faut se souvenir que justement
les roches se forment sur des échelles de
temps géologiques.
Le refroidissement du magma, quand il se produit
à l’intérieur de la terre, peut prendre
des milliers voire des millions d’années.
Et un minéral comme le quartz aura donc largement
le temps de cristalliser malgré la lenteur
du phénomène.
Evidemment une situation où ça n’est pas
forcément le cas, c’est quand le magma
se trouve refroidi très rapidement à la
surface, et c’est ce qui peut former des
roches comme l’obsidienne, qui a une structure
amorphe, et qui est donc une sorte de verre
naturel.
En conclusion, le verre peut donc être décrit
à la fois comme un solide amorphe, et un
liquide en surfusion extrêmement visqueux.
Donc en principe le verre coule, mais il coule
très très très lentement.
Evidemment c’est tellement lent que jamais
vous ne verrez votre bouteille de bière ou
vos fenêtre se mettre à couler sous vos
yeux.
Mais on raconte que si on observe des vitraux
d’ancienne églises, qui ont donc parfois
plusieurs siècles, on peut observer qu’ils
sont légèrement plus épais à la base,
du fait de l’écoulement très lent du verre
qui les constitue.
Mais en fait, cette histoire est vraisemblablement
une légende urbaine.
Il y a une publication assez argumentée à
ce sujet, mais si vous aimez les méthodes
rapides, on peut s’en convaincre avec un
petit calcul d’ordre de grandeur en utilisant
de l’analyse dimensionnelle, j’avais consacré
un épisode à cette technique.
Et on trouve que la variation d’épaisseur
du verre, du fait de son écoulement, devrait
être de l’ordre d’un nanomètre en un
milliard d’années.
Donc non, ça ne peut pas expliquer la forme
des vitraux !
Bien, maintenant qu’on a réglé son compte
à cette légende, je voudrais revenir sur
un sujet essentiel que j’ai pour l’instant
intentionnellement laissé de côté : la
composition du verre.
[jingle]
Jusqu’ici pour faire simple, j’ai fait
comme si le verre c’était uniquement fait
à partir de sable, donc du quartz, dont la
formule est SiO2.
Mais en pratique, on ajoute toujours d’autres
ingrédients.
Il y a deux motivations à cela : faciliter
la fabrication, et obtenir des verres avec
les propriétés qu’on souhaite.
Commençons par le procédé de fabrication.
Je vous ai dit que le quartz fondait autour
de 1700°C.
Donc en pratique si on veut faire fondre confortablement
du sable pur, il faut monter à des températures
proches de disons 2000°C, ce qui n’est
pas du tout évident.
On peut le faire, ça s’appelle faire du
verre de silice, mais c’est réservé à
certaines applications très spécifiques.
Pour du verre normal, on va devoir trouver
un moyen de ne pas monter autant en température.
Pour cela, on ajoute à la composition du
verre ce qu’on appelle des fondants, par
exemple le carbonate de sodium Na2CO3.
[FONDANT Sous l’effet de la chaleur, ce
minéral va d’abord se décomposer et libérer
du CO2, et l’oxyde de sodium Na2O qui reste
va permettre d’abaisser la température
de fusion de notre verre.
C’est a priori un peu contre-intuitif comme
mécanisme.
Le Na2O fond vers 1100°C, le SiO2 vers 1700°C.
Si on les mélange et qu’on chauffe le tout,
on pourrait s’attendre à ce que les grains
de Na2O fondent à 1100°C et ceux de SiO2
à 1700°C.
Mais en pratique, il se produit des réactions
chimiques entre les deux, ce qui a pour effet
d’abaisser la température de fusion de
l’ensemble, et même à des valeurs inférieures
aux deux température de fusion.]
[PHASE La valeur exacte de la température
de fusion du mélange va dépendre des proportions
des deux composants, mais ce sont des choses
documentées dans ce qu’on appelle un diagramme
de phase.
Je ne vous détaille pas tout mais ce diagramme
nous montre l’état thermodynamique du mélange
en fonction de la température et de la composition.
Ici on voit qu’avec un peu plus de 20% de
Na2O pour presque 80% de SiO2, la température
de fusion passera à moins de 1000°C.
Ce qui est quand même beaucoup plus simple
à atteindre que les 1700°C du quartz pur.]
Le problème c’est que l’ajout de Na2O
a aussi des effets secondaires indésirables,
comme la diminution de la stabilité thermique
et chimique du verre, ce qui peut notamment
le rendre trop soluble dans l’eau.
Ce serait un peu gênant.
Pour compenser cela, un autre oxyde que l’on
ajoute fréquemment, c’est l’oxyde de
calcium CaO qui permet de corriger ces problèmes
et obtenir un verre plus durable.
Le trio SiO2/Na2O/CaO, c’est la base de
la plupart des verres usuels : aussi bien
les bouteilles que les vitres des bâtiments
ou des voitures.
[VISCO Le verre de ce genre qu’on appelle
silico-sodo-calcique a des propriétés qui
le rendent bien plus facile à travailler
que le quartz pur.
Par comparaison vous voyez ici la courbe de
viscosité en fonction de la température.
C’est un verre qui va fondre aux environs
de 1000°C, et généralement on essaye de
se mettre autour de cette zone pour le travailler.
C’est là qu’il n’est ni trop visqueux,
ni trop mou.]
Historiquement, un oxyde que l’on a longtemps
ajouté pour faciliter le travail du verre,
c’est l’oxyde de plomb PbO2.
Ce dernier a plusieurs avantages : il abaisse
aussi la température de fusion ainsi que
la viscosité, rendant plus simple le travail
du verre quand on veut lui donner sa forme.
Mais l’oxyde de plomb a aussi un impact
sur les propriétés optiques du verre : il
augmente son indice de réfraction.
Cela le rend plus brillant et avec des reflets
plus colorés du fait de la meilleure séparation
des couleurs dans la dispersion de la lumière
blanche.
[CRISTAL Ce verre au plomb, plus joli que
la normale, on lui a donné dans le langage
courant une appellation bien étrange : on
appelle ça du cristal.]
Il y a des raisons historiques à cela, mais
vous comprenez que cette dénomination est
très perturbante.
Dans le langage courant, on va dire de ce
matériau «c’est du cristal» pour
sous-entendre «c’est pas du vulgaire
verre». Alors que sur le plan physique,
c’est justement aussi du verre, et donc
précisément pas un cristal.
A part ceux que j’ai déjà cité, il y
a tout un tas d’oxydes qu’on peut utiliser
en plus ou moins grande quantité pour modifier
les propriétés du verre : l’alumine, l’oxyde
de bore, de magnesium etc.
Et une des propriétés que l’on modifie
souvent dans le verre, c’est sa couleur.
Certains ions apportés par des oxydes spécifiques
comme les oxydes de fer ou de chrome possèdent
en effet des propriétés d’absorption qui
peuvent fortement colorer le verre.
C’est comme ça qu’on va lui donner toutes
les teintes que l’on connait par exemple
pour les bouteilles de bière ou de vin.
Sinon on peut même ajouter de l’oxyde d’uranium
et obtenir du verre fluorescent qu’on appelle
l’ouraline.
Parmi les autres propriétés que l’on souhaite
contrôler, j’en ai un peu parlé, il y
a la stabilité thermique ou chimique.
Pour des applications en verrerie de laboratoire
ou des flacons de pharmacie, on utilisera
par exemple de l’oxyde de bore B2O3 qui
améliore son inertie chimique.
Une autre propriété bien connue que l’on
cherche à maitriser, c’est le coefficient
de dilatation.
La dilatation thermique, vous le savez peut-être,
c’est ce qui fait qu’un matériau peut
augmenter de volume sous l’effet de la température.
Et c’est notamment ça qui cause les ruptures
par choc thermique.
[CHOC Si vous versez de l’eau bouillante
dans un verre ordinaire, la surface du verre
sera soumise d’un coup à une certaine dilatation,
tandis que l’intérieur ne chauffe pas tout
de suite et donc ne se dilate pas autant.
Cela crée des contraintes dans le verre qui
peuvent provoquer son éclatement, vous l’avez
peut-être déjà vécu.
C’est une rupture par choc thermique.]
Pour limiter ce phénomène, il faut essayer
d’abaisser le coefficient de dilatation
du verre.
Et c’est le principe du verre dit «Pyrex»,
dont la composition lui permet d’avoir un
coefficient de dilatation 2 à 3 fois plus
petit que celui du verre ordinaire.
Et donc de bien mieux résister aux chocs
thermiques.
Mais il existe deux autres applications encore
plus exigeantes, pour lesquelles on essaye
de se débarrasser des effets de la dilatation
thermique : les miroirs des télescopes, et
… les plaques de cuisson.
Les miroirs des télescopes, c’est pour
des raisons de stabilité de l’image, on
ne veut pas que les images soient floues à
cause de lègères variations de température
qui déforment le verre.
Pour les plaques de cuisson, c’est plutôt
pour éviter que la plaque ne s’use prématurément
à force de chauffer et de refroidir plusieurs
fois par jour.
Pour ces deux applications, on aimerait idéalement
un verre avec un coefficient de dilatation
de 0, ou du moins aussi faible que possible.
Mais ça c’est impossible à faire avec
du verre…sauf en ayant recours à une idée
géniale : la vitro-céramique.
Dans le langage courant, le terme «vitro-céramique»
a fini par désigner un type de plaque de
cuisson.
Mais en fait il s’agit au départ du nom
du matériau très spécial qui est utilisé
pour faire ces plaques, ces plaques qui extérieurement
ont l’air d’être en verre.
[VITROCERAMIQUE L’idée de la vitrocéramique,
c’est de partir d’un verre, donc ayant
une structure amorphe, et de forcer en son
sein l’apparition de microcristaux, grâce
à un traitement thermique particulier.
Une vitrocéramique, c’est donc une matrice
de verre amorphe qui emprisonne une certaine
proportion de microcristaux, d’où le terme
vitro-céramique.]
Et le truc génial, c’est qu’en choisissant
une composition bien spécifique, on peut
créer des microcristaux ayant un coefficient
de dilatation négatif.
C’est assez rare comme phénomène, mais
on connait un certain nombre de cristaux qui
dans une certaine plage de température font
l’inverse de la plupart des matériaux : ils
se contractent sous l’effet de la chaleur.
[DILATATION C’est notamment le cas de certains
cristaux obtenus à partir d’un mélange
d’oxyde de lithium, d’alumine et de silice.
Et donc l’idée géniale, c’est de partir
d’un verre contenant notamment ces oxydes,
et de faire apparaitre ces microcristaux dans
les bonnes proportions.
On obtient alors un matériau composite où
le coefficient de dilatation positif de la
matrice verrière est plus ou moins exactement
compensé par le coefficient de dilatation
négatif des cristaux.
Et donc au total cette vitrocéramique aura
un coefficient de dilatation quasiment nul.]
Il y a encore plein de choses qu’on pourrait
raconter sur le verre et ses dérivés, et
notamment les verres réalisés avec des oxydes
beaucoup plus exotiques que la silice SiO2,
par exemple les verres à base d’oxyde de
germanium ou de phosphate.
Sachez aussi que certains micro-organismes
sont capables de créer du verre, de la silice
amorphe, mais en utilisant un procédé chimique,
sans avoir à chauffer à 2000°C donc.
[DIATOMEES C’est le cas des diatomées,
ces microorganismes marins qui ont la capacité
de se fabriquer une minuscule coquille en
silice amorphe.]
Mais le principe du verre, celui d’un liquide
en surfusion très visqueux, ça ne s’applique
pas seulement aux oxydes minéraux.
Par exemple, on peut aussi faire des verres
métalliques.
On refroidit très rapidement du métal fondu
et on le piège dans une structure amorphe.
Faut juste refroidir vraiment très vite,
car contrairement au verre, le métal lui
ne demande qu’à cristalliser.
Et en laboratoire, on sait même faire un
truc incroyable : on sait faire des verres
d’eau.
Pas des verres d’eau, de l’eau solide
amorphe.
Mais pour ça il faut vraiment refroidir très
très vite, du genre arrive à faire passer
une goutte d’eau à -100°C en 1 milliseconde.
Oui c’est assez compliqué.
Mais c’est pour la science, pas pour refroidir
un pastis.
Voilà c’est tout pour aujourd’hui, je
vous laisse à la contemplation de vos glaçons,
de vos bouteilles de bière et de vos plaques
de cuisson.
Rendez vous sur le discord de science étonnante
pour prolonger la discussion, le lien est
en description, et je vous dit à très vite
pour une nouvelle vidéo, à bientôt.
MINIATURE